if you're a fan of Michael Jackson makes
under 50,000 people packed into
Cardiff's Millennium Stadium as Michael
Jackson and friends and fans celebrated
his contribution to music the tribute
concert which was attended by his
children went ahead despite the family
with we're very happy to be here on in
special later on her father some of the
Jacksons are unhappy that it coincided
with the involuntary manslaughter trial
of dr. Conrad Murray in LA Michael's
brothers Tito Marlon and Jackie defended
the decision to go ahead with the gig we
have a large family and half of them are
in court supporting the trial and other
half is here support of the celebration
everybody grieves totally different so
they have the elected to not to partake
in this and so we respect their decision
and we wanted to do this not only from
my Michael but for our mom and it it's
the positive side of everything so it
makes me feel good inside
Leona Lewis Christina Aguilera and Cee
Lo Green took to the stage as did latoya
jackson he performed in public for the
first time in 20 years I didn't know if
I wanted to do it or not that I said I
had to do it for him and so I said you
know whether you want to not do it for
him and that's what I did Motown stalls
Smokey Robinson and Gladys Knight with
that at the beginning of Jackson's
career and reflected on his legacy he's
going to live on forever because of the
contributions changed the music industry
completely nobody's ever done that in
life I mean you know we got greats up
there and Great's out there but then
Michael Jackson when you look at any of
the especially the younger generation of
entertainers they're all mimicking
Michael Jackson in some form or fashion
with the dancers behind them and they're
doing the dance steps with the dancers
and so on and so he had a great impact
Michael Jackson entertained the world
for over 40 years and last night's show
proves that even though he's no longer
hear his music can still fill in the
crowd
Jane with a spoon Sky News